für hitzige diskussionen sorgt die
volksinitiative bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen bereits im vorfeld der
abstimmung vom 15 juni 2016
ein grundeinkommen für alle ohne
bedingung ohne vorleistung für die einen
ist das blauäugig eine provokation für
die anderen steht ein zutiefst
christliche sun liegen dahinter
wie ist denn nun ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen aus christlicher sicht zu
beurteilen
darüber diskutieren jetzt cornelia hahn
michel groß sie ist evangelisch
reformierte pfarrerin in davos platz
sie ist für die initiative und peter
ruch er auch er ist evangelisch
reformierter pfarrer in küssnacht am
rigi ist ein gegner der initiative
was würde sich für sie frau kam michael
jetzt konkret ändern mit einem
bedingungslosen grundeinkommen
ich denke es würde sich die einstellung
zur arbeit die wir als familie leisten
ändern
wir sind immer noch gleich überzeugt
dass das was wir tun richtig und wichtig
ist aber es würde vom aus und hilft
vielleicht etwas verändert werden weil
mein mann ist selbstständig erwerben wir
teilen uns die hausarbeit familienarbeit
die erwerbsarbeit auf und dann würde
seine selbständige erwerbsarbeit auch
grundsätzlich enthüllt werden
also ohne eine bestimmte leistung
bereits verbringen sie haben drei kinder
im schulpflichtigen alter als auch bei
je nachdem wie hoch der beitrag ist
sie würden aber gleichwohl weiter
arbeiten ja wir sind jetzt schon so dass
wir eben die arbeit nach unseren
wünschen tun können wir sind
privilegiert so wie wir leben und darum
würde sich nicht sehr vieles an unserer
arbeit ändern aber ich glaube
gesamtgesellschaftlich würde sich etwas
ändern
was bringt sie denn jetzt als fans auf
die palme bei dieser initiative auf die
palme ist vielleicht zu viel gesagt aber
mir scheint dass wir in unseren
westlichen demokratien heute schon
reichlich viel staatliche umverteilung
praktizieren und das käme dann noch dazu
das wäre eine grosse eine große menge
von erwirtschafteten geld das hinzu käme
also dass wir statt um verteilt würde
und ich glaube es ist zwar keine
ökonomische diskussion aber mir scheint
das ist zunächst einmal nicht bezahlbar
und es ist auch ein widerspruch zum
menschlichen wesen der mensch möchte
nicht einfach geld bekommen sondern er
möchte etwas erarbeiten und dann an
dieser arbeit sich freuen und auch am
ertrag und das ist deswegen plädiere ich
immer für ein
für eine freie wirtschaft und für ein
freies erwerbsleben mit möglichst wenig
um verteilen also ein durch und durch
liberaler standpunkt haben jetzt die
finanzen angesprochen das natürlich
nicht das primäre anliegen jetzt unseres
gesprächs nur ganz kurz in dieser
bedingungslose grundeinkommen in der
initiative sagte das soll eingeführt
werden es soll der ganzen bevölkerung
ein menschenwürdiges dasein und die
teilnahme am öffentlichen leben
ermöglichen
das gesetz regelt insbesondere die
finanzierung und die höhe des
grundeinkommens also das wird im
initiativtext er dann ein geschrieben
würde bei einer annahme in die
verfassung ist das ist offen geblieben
oder die höhe dieses grundeinkommen
aber es gibt natürlich zahlen die kurse
2500 franken pro person genau sagen die
initianten aber der initiativtext lässt
das offen
sie sagen das menschenbild sprechen sie
an der mensch ist sozusagen habe ich das
richtig gehört
prädestiniert um reformer
durchzusprechen für die arbeit das würde
ich sagen also auch von der bibel her
im schweiße deines angesichts sollst du
dein brot essen das ist nicht noch eine
drohung sondern auch eine verheißung
selbstverständlich gibt es menschen die
nicht arbeitsfähig sind sei es weil sich
noch kinder sind sei es weil sie alt
sind oder weil sie behindert sind für
diese menschen müssen wir aufkommen das
geschieht ja auch du sonst keine frage
aber dass man nun allen ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen zu
spricht das halte ich für grotesk und
eben auch für gefährliches hätte auch
die auswirkung dass die menschen aus dem
tiefen einkommen segment gar keinen
anreiz mehr hätten zu arbeiten
es kommt hinzu wir werden doch auch über
die finanzierung noch sprechen müssen
das ist auch eine ethische frage
es kommt hinzu dass es wahrscheinlich
nicht finanzierbar wäre ohne die folge
einer massenverarmung unserer
bevölkerung also noch eine steile these
bleiben wir mal bei der frage der
motivation da habe ich nämlich sprechen
die bibel an
wenn wir schon zwei theologen hier haben
einen satz gefunden so werden die
letzten die ersten sein und die ersten
die letzten einsatz der am ende eines
eigentlich verstörenden gleichnisses im
matthäus-evangelium steht und als ein
weinberg da werden arbeiter geholt der
letzte arbeitet eine stunde kriegt aber
gleich viel lohn wie die arbeiter die
den ganzen tag unter der sonne
geschuftet haben kriegen gleich
wildungen beschweren sich natürlich auch
verständlicherweise von unserem gefühl
her steht aber so in der bibel steht so
in der bibel das ist so und ich würde
das auch in einen sozial sozialen
kontext stellen also ich würde das jetzt
nicht gerade als das gleichnis aufnehmen
für ein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
es ist ein gleichnis dass die
verhältnisse widerspiegelt die damals
gegolten haben das war ein grund her die
sich das leisten konnte
die tagelöhner einfach dann einzustellen
wenn er sie braucht und dafür heißt es
aber das ist nicht richtig weil die
menschen brauchen etwas zum leben ganz
grundsätzlich und da müsste man schauen
dass sie eben weil sie zur verfügung
stehen und auch erwerb erwerbseinkommen
brauchen auch diesen grundsatz erfüllt
also muss her der für den ausgleich
sorgen es ist ein gut hätte für den
ausgleich sorgen aber die tagelöhner
sind ganz stark von ihm abhängig und von
seinem wohlwollen und das ist klar
ich nicht das was ganz zuerst da steht
von diesen bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen
was würden sie denn in der bibel
herausziehen für das grundeinkommen
ich würde daraus herausziehen das
bedingungslos wir alles haben eigentlich
schon in unserer umwelt mit unserer
natur mit der schöpfung was wir
eigentlich brauchen also das ist
grundsätzlich allen gegeben
und dass wir das bewirtschaften und das
auch nutzen können das ist ganz wichtig
aber es soll für alle gleich zugänglich
sein
also ganz grundsätzlich sind wir so wie
wir als menschen sind von gott gewollt
und bedingungslos geliebt also gott ist
barmherzig und gnädig das ist das
reformatorische und reformatorische
aussage die ins bewusstsein gerückt ist
wieder vor 500 jahren dass das in
zuallererst steht und dass wir alle
gleichermaßen an diesem grundsatz
teilhaben können
ich habe noch etwas was ist was ich
gerne erwidern würde sie haben die alten
menschen die kinder und die menschen mit
einer behinderung genannt und das sind
ja genau diese menschen die jetzt schon
ein grundeinkommen haben also dass das
würde ich da nicht so bei ziehen um
gegen ein grundeinkommen zu sprechen
sozialversicherung die
sozialversicherung bestimmt habe schon
gegeben und das ist auch ihr wichtig und
das ist auch ganz nötig ich würde den
aspekt auf etwas anderes legen dass die
menschen ja sowieso schon arbeiten also
es gibt es so und so viele menschen die
jetzt schon ohne entlohnung arbeiten und
dass das die ganze care sektor gemeint
also die freiwilligenarbeit aber auch
die arbeit einfach getan werden muss die
nicht immer nur freiwillig vonstatten
geht und das sind mehrheitlich frauen
die diese arbeit leistet also zum
beispiel die erziehungsarbeit den haben
jetzt noch kinder im schulpflichtigen
alter sie haben auch drei söhne und
töchter die aber jetzt schon erwachsen
sind zum teil wieder mit eigenen kindern
also sie kennen ja die thematik auch
noch
gutes argument ich würde sagen wenn man
jetzt von zweieinhalb tausend franken
ausgeht pro monat beim bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen dann ist das natürlich
antrag der niemals reichen würde
für den aufwand zum beispiel den
behinderte menschen unter umständen
erfordern um sie zu betreuen
es ist auch gar nicht klar ob die
initiative wenn sie angenommen würde die
abschaffung des ganzen sozialstaates zur
folge hätte oder ob das so wie sie
formuliert ist kommt sie einfach oben
drauf zu dem was wir schon haben
und das wäre meines erachtens vollkommen
abwegig und wenn der sozialstaat dafür
abgeschafft würde dann hätten wir die
situation dass wir nicht mehr gezielt
helfen wir helfen dann pauschal und ich
sehe nicht ein warum ein gesunder
arbeitsfähiger mensch vom staat
irgendetwas bekommen sollte das ja
selber erwirtschaften kann
vielleicht noch ein wort zum gleichnis
material aber sei es jetzt zu dem weil
das interessiert mich das ist ja die
frage der motivation oder auch in diesem
gleichnis
also ich würde auch sagen wenn ich für
eine stunde gleich viel geld krieg wie
der andere für den ganzen tag dann gehe
ich doch am nächsten tag gehe ich nur
mehr eine stunde arbeiten wie ein
kräften sie dieses argument also da bin
ich falsch verstanden worden ich gehe
nicht nur eine stunde arbeiten
vielleicht haben diese leute ja vorher
schon ganz was anderes getan
sie waren da und haben sich gesorgt um
angehörige serben vielleicht bei den
hausaufgaben geholfen sie haben die die
straßen geputzt gekehrt oder für das
allgemeinwohl gesorgt sie haben politik
betrieben das kann alles dazu gehören
also für mich wäre es ganz wichtig auch
in dieser ganzen diskussion zu
definieren was ist denn eigentlich
arbeit und die auch zu lösen von der
erwerbsarbeit das wäre für mich der
grundsatz bevor ich überlege ob es
bezahlbar ist oder nicht möchte dahin
oder es ist nur es ist es widerspricht
den tatsachen wir hatten in früheren
zeiten als die leute also als wir noch
weniger sozialstaat hatten
da war es leichter
für freiwilligenarbeit leute zu finden
zugegebenermaßen hauptsächlich frauen
aber nicht ausschließlich auch die
männer leisteten viel freiwilligenarbeit
und heute ist das schwieriger
und wenn wir das beispiel frankreich
anschauen da hat man seit jahrzehnten
die 35 stunden woche sie wurde damals
eingeführt unter anderem mit dem
argument dass die leute dann mehr zeit
hätten um freiwilligen arbeit zu leisten
oder um anderen zu dienen oder wie auch
immer
und das hat sich nicht bewahrheitet denn
wir dürfen eines nicht vergessen der
mensch ist von natur aus auch in einem
gerüttelt maß ein egoist
also ich bin das zum beispiel und ich
stelle das bei anderen leuten auch fest
das entspricht auch den biblischen
menschenbild der mensch ist ein sünder
und der interpretiert die umstände und
die verhältnisse zu seinen gunsten
und das ist nicht selten zu ungunsten
der anderen darf ich noch ein wort zum
gleichnis gleichwohl der faule sack als
bild des menschen in der bibel das
wollten ist auch von ihnen noch hören ja
jetzt ist nicht nur sind rede ist auch
damit es auch gerecht gesprochen und und
kann aus diesem heraus dann antworten
also wir haben die zehn gebote die
eingeführt werden ich habe euch befreit
und aus dieser befreiungs erfahrung
heraus antworten die menschen dann und
dann sagen sie man kann das auch anders
übersetzen als du sollst etwas tun
sondern du wirst etwas tun oder du
willst etwas tun also aus dieser
befreiungs erfahrung heraus möchte ich
dankbar
der mensch ist auch dankbar zurück geben
und mich beteiligen in diesem kreislauf
der ganz notwendig ist und darum denke
ich dass der mensch lernfähig ist also
aus der erfahrung auch das sünden
vergeben werden kann ich auch etwas
anderes tun dann eben nicht mehr zu
sündigen natürlich hier sind die sünden
vergeben und sündigen fahrt nicht mehr
sid - simon pk torhüter sagte also
zugleich zugleich gerecht gesprochen und
zugleich sind es ist beides ist es ist
ein dialektisches verhältnisse
da auch ein widerspruch sollte noch
einmal der mensch in den zehn geboten
hat es auch eine ökonomische aussage
nämlich den eigentumsschutz du sollst
nicht stehlen
und ich frage mich ob wir dieses gebot
einhalten können wenn wir mehr steuern
erheben müssen dass wir jedem menschen
so viel geld geben wie wird das genannt
haben das sind 200 milliarden pro jahr
wäre das in der schweiz das ist die das
ist die kopf rechnung nicht warum das
wir noch nicht bestritten 209 milliarden
auf der basis der zahnarzt weiter genau
was reden wir von 200 milliarden die
sozial die soziale umverteilung die wir
jetzt haben und die in den letzten
jahrzehnten massiv gestiegen ist um fast
ohne die zweite säule welche angespannt
ist 70 milliarden
das heißt wir müssten massiv aufstocken
und das würde nur mit mit großen mit
großen steuererträgen und abschöpfungen
könnte das gelingen
und dann würde der staat wohl gegen das
gebot du sollst nicht stehlen verstoßen
und das ist für mich auch ein
theologisch ethisches problem bzw ein
grund den vorstoß abzulehnen
darf ich noch kurz etwas sagen zu um zum
gleichnis matthäus 20 nur ganz kurz es
ist ein reich gottes gleichnis und es
lebt vom kontrast
es beschreibt implizit die verhältnisse
die wir menschen im herzen haben nämlich
dass wir pro stunde bezahlt werden
proportional zur leistung das ist der
normalfall
und jetzt übersteigt das gleichnis diese
verhältnisse weil es eben vom reich
gottes redet im reich gottes ist es
anders aber hier auf der erde ist es nun
mal so dass die ökonomie und das heißt
ja nicht anders als bei cosmos also die
gesetzmäßigkeit des hauses und den
haushalt das gilt aber im reich gottes
ist es anders und es gibt ja nur
warnungen des reiches gottes zu stellen
das jetzt in den kontext historisch dass
bei eine frage davon über biblische
argumentieren mit texten die 2000 jahre
alt sind ich versuche doch noch mal
denn wer hat dem wird gegeben und er
wird im überfluss haben wir aber nicht
hat den wird auch noch weggenommen was
er hat
nochmals auf eine andere art eigentlich
ein gegenbeispiel im gleichen
matthäus-evangelium kurz später ein
gleichnis wo wiederum ein gutsherr der
verreist talente also geld verteilt der
eine vermehrt es der wird belohnt für
seine frau der andere der ein talent hat
und am schluss auch nur eins wo der
gutsherr wieder zurückkommt den wirt
weggenommen
das schmeckt ihnen jetzt schon besser
oder wobei das natürlich auch ein
gleichnis ist das von der ökonomie
schließlich zu dem zum zum menschen über
leitet also das talent war eine
geldeinheit ist dann zum inbegriff
worten von begabungen mit denen man
etwas anfangen soll
interessant an dem gleichnis finde ich
nicht zuletzt die tatsache dass ein zins
er befürwortet wird und denn das ist ja
eine prämie für für eine für
konsumverzicht nicht wahr
wenn ich geld habe und geld verdiene und
das nicht gleich verbraucher und das
endlager jemand anderem
dann bekomme ich dafür eine prämie weil
ich auf den konsum zunächst einmal
verzichtet und das ist vernünftig und
das sorgt auch dafür dass man mit den
ressourcen haushälterisch umgehen
die nullzinspolitik verhindert dass das
ist ja aber ich muss also bevor wir eine
zins debatte bibel haben sie befürworten
also die leistung des menschen der soll
was tun soll was draus machen dem
widerspricht für sie aber das
grundeinkommen nicht nein absolut nicht
weil es wird ja gearbeitet
also ich gehe wirklich davon aus dass
das gern dass der mensch grundsätzlich
etwas tun will also wenn wir kinder
beobachten die beim spielen immer weiter
kommen und sich selber auch so
weiterentwickeln und viel lernen kann
dann ist das ganz klar dass sie auch das
ist auch arbeit das ist lernen arbeit
das übertragen das erwachsenen
es hätte ein experiment das neueste nzz
folio oben und unten ruft das noch mal
in erinnerung aus den 1970 er jahren
allerdings sind kanada mit 1000
haushalten die mit so einem
grundeinkommen
sozusagen beglückt wurden die aber auch
darauf angewiesen waren
nur ein prozent der männer drei prozent
der verheirateten frauen und 5 prozent
der unverheirateten frauen arbeiteten
nach der einführung von mincom so ist
das projekt weniger als zuvor
das heißt die demotivierende wirkung die
sie unterstellt haben wir hier nicht
gegeben
das könnte natürlich an der
laborsituation liegen die leute wussten
wohl dass das experiment oder der
versuch nicht ewig dauern würde und sie
behielten ihre lebensform bei weil sie
wussten dass das eines tages beendet ist
das wäre aber an dass wenn man das
definitiv hineinführt mit einer
verfassungsbestimmung dann würden vor
allem leute die gering qualifiziert sind
die würden vor der frage stehen verdiene
ich überhaupt mehr wenn ich arbeite und
diese frage wäre in manchen fällen zu
verneinen
und dann hätten hätte man ein problem
dort erstens bei der erfüllung dieser
menschen und zweitens auch bei der
beisetzung von arbeiten also wir kommen
hier nicht weiter sie sagen würden
weniger arbeiten sie sagen sie würden in
anderen feldern beispiel kinder arbeiten
jetzt haben wir schon hier eine
evangelisch reformierte theologie geht
schreibt wird die theologen an die zahl
interessiert mich doch also es gibt ja
dieses ich sag dem jetzt bewusst
klischee seit max weber was der
protestantismus besonders verbunden ist
mit den kapitalismus das ist eine
verbindung gibt also besondere fleiß
ablesbar durch die religion dann auch am
wirtschaftlichen erfolg ist da was dran
man sagt ja auch es sei ein klischee
dass max weber das nicht so eng gesehen
hat und so eng gefasst hat dass er da
missverstanden worden ist es gab
natürlich bewegungen auch die dass die
leistung auch dann mit den früchten an
denen man sie erkennen wird gleich
gesetzt haben
ich würde aber beim reformatorischen
verstehen
mit der arbeit an beginnen auch nochmals
und und dort ist es ja bei zwingli so
gewesen dass er den geistlichen stand
also der wieder aktiver gegenüber
gesetzt hat also der gewitter
kontemplativen die vita activa sollten
gleichwertig sein und nicht
gegeneinander ausgespielt werden und ein
geistlicher stand oder den adelsstand
sollte quasi heruntergeholt werden und
gleichgesetzt werden
und ich möchte da ansetzen und sagen das
müsste man wieder hervorholen dass
sämtliche arbeit gleichwertige arbeit
ist und nicht irgendwie nur
erwerbsarbeit ins zentrum gestellt wird
es wird immer von geld gesprochen es
geht sehr viel um geld und für mich geht
es bei diesem einkommen dass man endlich
mal nicht mehr vom geld sprechen müsste
sondern auch vom sinn des lebens und da
tun sehr viele tätigkeiten sind da um
einen sinn verwirklichen zu können und
das finde ich etwas ganz wichtiges
ich bin mit ihnen einverstanden dass man
vielleicht weniger vom geld sprechen
sollte das geld ist eine abstraktion des
tauschwert es nicht wahr wenn man
freiwilligenarbeit macht beruht hat
beruhten beruhen die leistungen auch
nicht selten auf einem tausch zum
beispiel hütet man sich gegenseitig die
kinder von haus braucht man kein geld
auszutauschen
man tauscht die leistung aus aber weil
unsere unsere wirtschaft und unsere
gesellschaft so komplex geworden ist
brauchen wir gutscheine und das ist das
geld
nun ist das geld tatsächlich eine
versuchung das ist auch in der bibel so
aber wir brauchen das geld gleichwohl
wenn wir den wohlstand einigermaßen
erhalten sollen brauchen wir diese
abstraktion wir können nicht zum
tauschhandel zurück
aber wir dürfen nicht unser herz an das
geld hängen
das ist das ist völlig klar vielleicht
noch ein wort zu max weber ja eben das
arbeitsethos ist es nun im zentrum des
protestantismus oder nicht
sie haben das jetzt relativiert also mag
ich glaube die these von max weber ist
nach wie vor richtig aber dass man sie
ist ergänzungsbedürftig
ich habe unlängst einen aufsatz gelesen
mit einer ergänzung die mir sinnvoll
scheint dass zum beispiel für den erfolg
der protestantischen regionen der sich
der nachweisbar ist empirisch das ist
keine frage da sei nicht nur diese diese
idee der empfehlung maßgebend gewesen
sondern auch die bildung also man hat in
den protestantischen gebieten die
bildung viel stärker gepusht als in den
katholischen und das zeigt zum beispiel
die interessante tatsache dass
katholische minderheiten in
protestantischen gebieten ebenso
erfolgreich waren wie die protestanten
weil sie in diesem bildungssystem drin
waren
man wollte ja die bibel lesen und hat
deswegen schon seit der reformation sich
bemüht dass die leute lesen und
schreiben können nicht durchwegs mit der
folge oder nicht mit raschen erfolg
manchmal auch kam das spät aber die
bildung war ein wichtiger faktoren also
den gibt es natürlich auch im
katholizismus mit den ganzen orden
natürlich schulen gegründet haben
aber sie würden wirklich eben die these
von max weber finde ich interessant ja
sie ist auch heute noch zum
grundeinkommen zurück also was spricht
jetzt was ist das wichtigste argument
sag jetzt mal für sie für dieses
grundeinkommen
ich wäre wirklich die vorstellung dass
man einmal ein
wir brauchen das geld da pflichte ich
ihnen bei wir sind heute nicht mehr so
dass wir einfach gute gaben gegen andere
gute gaben eintauschen können
das ist so darum plädiere ich für ein
grundeinkommen weil es uns dann zeigt
was alles geleistet wird also dass die
ganze arbeit die getan werden muss auch
getan werden kann ohne dass man
irgendwie eher einer erwerbsarbeit
unbedingt nachgehen muss die vielleicht
weniger sehen macht als das was man
notwendigerweise tun muss also spreche
auch die bereiche was sie schon gegen
reichenberger bereiche sich ganz in den
fingern und die werden auch in zukunft
verstärkt kommen weil eben viele
menschliche arbeit von von computern
genommen werden aber haben sie nicht
dann bedenken dass jetzt gerade für die
frauen eine man sagt man herdprämie
jahresgehalt wird und sie dann wieder an
den herd eben also ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen kann nicht ohne die
geschlechterfrage stattfinden also es
ist ganz wichtig dass männer auch einen
sinn sehen in der care arbeitet dass sie
auch das gerne übernehmen würden und das
aufteilen würden dass da nicht neue
ungerechtigkeiten stattfinden dass die
herdprämie dann an ausländische frauen
und männer delegiert werden quasi dass
diese die arbeit dann übernehmen die wir
als gut situierte schweizerinnen und
schweizer nicht mehr machen werden die
einsätze kommentiert jetzt wo die
ausgestaltung sozusagen vorgestellt wird
vor wenigen tagen am vierten märz mit
blick auf die vielen millionen
arbeitslosen in europa ist es ein hohen
in der reichen schweiz mit einem gratis
schreck von 2500 franken zu wählen
wenn das so ihre position ja das ist
meine position und zwar auch aus
theologischen gründen es nicht weiter
start ist der grundsätzlich nicht
zuständig für den lebensunterhalt der
menschen das ist mal das erste und
systeme die sich dafür zuständig fühlten
und dann die menschen zu untertanen und
zu sklaven machten gab es schon immer
und es gab es ja auch in der bibel
ägypten war so ein system das war auch
der vater staat für alles zuständig und
josef hütete jati vorratsspeicher um
seine brüder kauften beim 1
und der clou ist ja dann das die
geburtsstunde des judentums darin
besteht dass man aus diesem system
hinaus geht in ein system der freiheit
des individualismus und der persönlichen
verantwortung vor gott und wenn wir auf
den sozialstaat den wir bereits haben
das noch drauf packen was sie
befürworten oder auch nur das allein
einführen und das andere abschaffen die
abschaffung wäre aber nicht machbar
dann machen wir die menschen immer mehr
abhängig und sie werden zu untertanen
und es droht wirklich
der verlust der freiheit und das wäre
ganz weit von der bibel weg interessant
wie weit ihre positionen auseinander
liegen auch als religiös aus religiöser
sicht argumentiert die debatte hat erst
richtig begonnen eine volksinitiative
will ja auch eine debatte auslösen
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für
dieses gespräch war kam michael und herr
will mit dem thema arbeit geht es hier
jetzt gleich weiter wir brauchen nicht
weniger sondern bessere arbeit das sagt
der philosoph thomas waschki denn arbeit
gehört für ihn zu einem guten leben dazu
stimmt das